and now move on to
the
final murder investigation
that of olivia pratt corbell
poor olivier
was murdered brutally
in our own home on the 22nd of august
our officers continue to carry out
extensive inquiries
and i can confirm that there are a
number of very positive lines of inquiry
that we are pursuing
in my previous appeal
i asked for the man responsible for this
brutal
callous thoughtless attack
to surrender himself
to the police
unfortunately that individual has failed
to do that
but my message to him remains the same
we will not rest until we find you
and we will find you
again
as i've said with the appeals around
both sam and ashley i cannot stress
enough the importance of community
engagement
in solving each of these crimes
we've had a wealth of information and
engagement and i'm incredibly grateful
for that
i can confirm
that the 35 year old man who was the
target of this attack
remains in hospital
seeking treatment
i can also confirm
that merseyside police
working with its partners
have caused that male's license to be
revoked
and he'll be returned
to prison once his treatment has been
finalized
i can also confirm
and ask directly
for communities to give us information
for the second man that was in company
with that 35 year old man
and again i can now confirm that we have
identified that mail
i've repeatedly asked for any
information and help from our
communities
and as i've said already in this
conference i am incredibly grateful for
the sheer levels and volume of
information that we receive so far
this level of engagement
this level of cooperation and this level
of working together
simply must continue
i hope our communities have also seen
some of our responses over the last few
days to the information that they're
providing
i also need to remind everybody around
the mip
opportunity on our website it's the
major incident portal to upload cctv and
make contact with us directly
through the met or indeed through crime
stoppers on our 800 555 111
i would very much like to be able to
provide further information at this time
however and i hope everyone can
understand and as i said at the start
it's simply not appropriate to divulge
anything further at this stage as these
are live investigations and we cannot do
anything that would prejudice the
outcome of them
i'd also say that these investigations
are incredibly fast paced
and
incredibly complex
but despite this
there are
multiple lines of inquiry that we are
actively pursuing
i'd like to reassure our communities
that are working relentlessly on each of
those murder investigations
and those main lines of inquiry are
being pursued effectively
i really do appreciate as i've said
repeatedly the engagement we've had thus
far i'd ask for it to continue and also
i appreciate the support that we have
had from the media as well
thank you very much